Sometime in the next decade, the International
Space Station will begin a slow descent from
orbit.
A gradual decline in its 400 kilometers altitude,
bringing the massive structure down to thicker
and thicker layers of our atmosphere before
it reaches a point of no return, 280 kilometers
above our heads.
From here air resistance will rapidly slow
down the station and begin to tear it apart.
Disintegrating over a planned debris field
centered around Point Nemo, the furthest point
from any landmass on Earth.
The South Pacific Oceanic Uninhabited Area.
Here, in Earth's watery spacecraft graveyard,
the remains of the ISS will lay after over
2 decades of valuable service to humankind.
But this all begs the question.
Why?
Why decommission such a valuable piece of
space infrastructure?
The ISS has been growing gradually since the
very first components of the station reached
orbit.
On November 20th 1998, the Zarya Cargo Module,
the first module of the ISS, launched aboard
a Russian Proton Rocket from Kazakhstan. [1]
Zarya was the seed for what was to come.
Carrying with it the docking, electrical power,
propulsion and guidance systems needed to
gradually grow what was to become an unprecedented
piece of international space infrastructure.
Zarya was joined just two weeks later by the
Unity Module.
A module with 2 axial connection points, one
on either end of the module, and 4 radial
connection points around its circumference.
Where the first truss segments would be attached,
allowing massive solar arrays to deploy and
provide power for the growing space laboratory.
These sections of the International Station
remain in space to this day, providing for
the needs of over 250 individual astronauts
in orbit around Earth over the past 23 years.
But this home in space was never intended
to be permanent, and many components are showing
their age.
The Zarya module, that seed from which the
entire space station grew, has developed several
cracks that are going to continually grow.
Cyclical thermal expansion, caused by the
16 sunsets and sunrises the ISS witnesses
each and every day, stresses the structure
of the station and causes these modules to
gradually degrade over time.
While jolts from spacecraft docking with the
space station can also cause stress in the
structure.
Not to mention the constant bombardment from
micrometeorites and space debris that has
damaged vital components of the ISS, like
the strike on the Canadarm in 2021.
[2]
Mystery pressure leaks have even forced Astronauts
into wild goose chases seaking the source
as their atmosphere slowly vents to space
[3] Problems like this have been cropping
up more and more frequently as the station
ages.
These modules, part of the primary structure
of the ISS, are what will limit the life of
the station, and at some point the modules
will need to be retired, the question is when.
Each participating partner of the ISS is expected
to inspect and perform life extending maintenance,
and while the
North American, Canadian, European and Japanese
space agencies have performed these checks
through to 2028, however, critically, Russia,
who have now become an international pariah,
have only completed these checks through to
2024.
[4] Limiting the ISS’s current lifetime
to just 2 years.
The war in the Ukraine has thrown NASA’S
recent transition and decommissioning report,
which planned to deorbit the ISS by 2031,
into limbo.
Without Russian cooperation the transition
plan is unfeasible, as the International Space
Station was never designed to have large sections
of its structure removed to allow a participating
partner to cease cooperation.
Without Russia, we may only have 2 years of
operation of the International Space Station
left, potentially dooming NASAs future plans
laid out in the transition report.
To understand what we may have just lost let’s
dive into the decommissioning and transition
report.
Short pause in edit.
Flipping through pages of the report animation
NASA has been planning this decommissioning
for some time, and for good reason.
The International Space Station costs NASA
roughly 3 billion dollar every year.
With the costs split fairly evenly between
the cost of transporting astronauts and supplies
to orbit and system operations and maintenance
of the station itself.
To put that into perspective, 3 billion is
over 10% of NASA’s total 24 billion dollar
budget and over a third of their human space
flight budget.
To really put that into perspective, the Perseverance
rover mission cost a total of 2.7 billion
dollars.
[5]
These costs are the real reason the ISS will
be decommissioned.
The transition report lays out a plan to decommission
the International Space Station to create
up to 1.8 billion dollars a year in budget
that could be used for NASA’s moon colony
goals.
That’s exciting in itself, but is losing
the international space station in the process
worth it?
Well, luckily, the transition plan lays out
how NASA will not only free up 1.8 billion
dollars of annual budget, but also maintain
a presence in orbit.
Commercial space flight has rapidly changed
the face of the space industry in the last
10 years.
In fact with the current state of affairs
with the war in Ukraine, without SpaceX, NASA
would be unable to send astronauts to the
ISS, as the Falcon 9 is the only American
rocket fully certified for transporting humans
to the ISS.
It is this advancement in the private space
industry that is going to allow NASA to maintain
a presence in orbit, while saving enough money
to fund a perseverance rover every 18 months.
The bulk of this money saving will be achieved
by offloading the development and maintenance
of the next generation of orbiting space habitats
to the commercial space industry.
NASA has long desired to do this, and the
benefits are clear with the success of SpaceX.
Whose innovation and pricing have forced the
entire industry to adapt.
Commercial industry is competitive, but in
order to allow the commercial space industry
to flourish in low earth orbit, there must
be something to sell.
A viable economy must exist.
In order to stimulate this new economy, NASA
has conducted studies to identify the most
promising enterprises that could find their
home in the next generation space station,
and several of those enterprises were part
of the transition plan for the ISS.
NASA identified a couple of key industries
that could flourish in space.
The first of which is the entertainment industry.
Imagine a world where the battle room of Ender’s
game is possible.
That’s a world that Space Entertainment
Enterprises is seeking to create.
With their spherical inflatable movie studio,
they are slated to film an unnamed movie with
Tom Cruise as the leading actor.
This however would not be a one off production.
The studio would be rentable by anyone with
a high enough budget.
A brave new world where I would put money
on MrBeast flying himself to space for a video.
Isn’t that right Jimmy?
This isn’t just a pie in the sky idea.
In 2020, NASA awarded Axiom space a contract
worth 140 million dollars to launch a module
that would attach to the ISS in 2024, which
will provide accommodation for private astronauts
and continue scientific research.
This is the first step in a planned expansion
of a private section of the International
Station, which, if successful, will be followed
by additional modules that would allow the
Axiom space station to operate completely
independently from the ISS and expand on the
other industries that NASA identified as potentially
profitable space economies.
The Space Entertainment Enterprises module
is part of this plan.
Microgravity manufacturing was another industry
identified.
Manufacturing without the influence of gravity
has some major advantages that are just waiting
for the right product that can justify the
cost of shipping raw materials to space.
Processes that are driven by gravity, like
sedimentation, convection, and hydrostatic
pressure are eliminated, which affect manufacturing
processes.
Sedimentation for example makes it very difficult
to create an evenly mixed liquid, as denser
particles sink to the bottom.
Say when we are creating an alloyed metal
with difficult density elements.
[6] These non-uniformities can affect the
material properties of the final metal component,
and so there is huge potential to create new
higher quality superalloys in space.
This is just one of many potential manufacturing
techniques that could be employed in space,
and we will discuss the topic in detail in
a future video.
With the current transition plan, this Axiom
commercial space station will detach from
the ISS in 2028, becoming the new seed from
which the space station can continue to grow
and provide a space for future NASA astronauts
to work from, with rental payments due to
Axiom and transportation costs to SpaceX.
There is a lot to look forward to with that
plan, but what are the chances this goes ahead
with Russia’s invasion of Ukraine making
it impossible to work with them.
Russia’s segments rely on America’s segments
for power, and the USA segments rely on Russian
propulsion to stay in orbit and avoid space
debris.
This is an international space station that
relies on international cooperation.
It’s clear that Russian astronauts oppose
the war in Ukraine, based on their recent
uniform change, but they do not call the shots
here.
The reality is, if this continues, NASA will
need to make some major decisions in the next
two years.
There are a few potential outcomes here.
The Russian’s separating their modules is
not one of them.
[7] As they need that power from the rest
of the ISS and would struggle to complete
that work without the help of the Canadian
robotic arm.
Russia could, under some miracle, get its
shit together in the next 2 years and remove
Putin’s regime and continue international
cooperation in space.
Or, Russia's segments may not be certified
through to 2028, forcing the deorbiting of
the International Space Station to be advanced,
with the transition to a commercial space
station abandoned.
Alternatively, emergency funds could be allocated
to NASA to rapidly supply the ISS with additional
modules to replace Russian services, like
propulsion for orbit maintenance and debris
avoidance, allowing the transition plans to
continue on as normal.
Or, the funds could simply be allocated to
the commercial space companies to accelerate
transition plans, but that is a massive ask
for unproven vendors in a 2 year timeframe.
One thing is for sure.
The current structure of the ISS is on borrowed
time.
Its aging primary structure is becoming a
larger and larger issue every year, and at
some point in the next decade, it will be
deorbited.
The only question now is when.
It’s hard to believe that the International
Space Station has been in orbit for just over
twenty years.
It’s been a huge source of inspiration for
aspiring engineers and scientists around the
world, a frontier of scientific research.
With only 253 individual astronauts from 19
different countries getting the privilege
to visit and work from the ISS, it’s seen
by many as the pinnacle scientific career
achievement.
A joy only a few of us will ever get to experience.
Luckily we can all get our little dose of
joy of scientific learning from Brilliant.
That dopamine rush of solving a problem you
have been trying to figure out is what drove
me towards a career in engineering.
Brilliant has refined that fun interactive
learning down perfectly to motivate you to
continue your learning through difficult subjects.
You can start your learning journey on any
number of courses, from neutral networks and
algorithms to statistics and probability.
You can learn at your own pace, learn on the
go with their mobile app, and most importantly
of all enjoy the process.
If you are stuck on a particular question,
Brilliant does not punish you and impede your
progress, instead they give you an in depth
explanation to guide you on your learning
path.
You can try Brilliant for free with the link
in the description or by clicking the button
on screen now, and the first 200 people to
sign up will get 20% off Brilliant Premium,
for a year of STEM learning in 2022.
If you are looking for something else to watch
right now you could watch our last video on
the insane engineering of the Concorde, or
you could watch Real Science’s new video
on the science of surviving in space.